Samantha's dad after a stabbing on an
RTC bus it happened earlier this evening
on Paradise near Desert Inn that's where
we find Madison Kimbrough live tonight
with the latest Madison
still an active scene out here behind me
as you can see but this is what we know
so far that RTC bus you see is where two
men were riding in when they got into an
argument the bus traveling Northbound on
Paradise at the time that's when one of
the men took out a knife and stabbed the
other it's unclear where that man was
stabbed but he was rushed to the
hospital where he later died we can
confirm that the suspect is no longer a
threat as he was taken into custody by
police while still on the bus as of now
it's still unclear the exact time the
stabbing took place but of course we
will bring you the latest details on air
and online at 8newsnow.com traffic is
pretty light on the Northbound side
right here but that is the RTC bus that
was involved in the incident sending it
back to you